um Luke okay Luke has been asking this
question at least 10 times in the chat
Luke I'm hearing you there's a ton of
questions we're gonna we're gonna get it
this is her you Luke okay Luke says I'm
a young entrepreneur and people keep
telling me or giving me the feeling that
I won't be successful what advice do you
have Wow Luke etch it safe summit one
thinks the blew me away I went on the
floor and we did loads of mentoring I
met a fourteen-year-old entrepreneur on
a second business idea I loved it it
blew me away God so Luke I don't know
what age you are but um there's so many
people and maybe maybe this is maybe
it's a little bit ageist but um
particularly some older people who
probably will tell you the reasons why
it's not such a good idea but if you
believe in it and then you know do
everything we've talked about previous
programs good test your idea test drive
it ro test it you can road test it with
your friends you can road test it on
social and you can create following and
that will give you the energy and
positivity to know that your ideas get a
land but I how do you know if an idea is
not going to land if you don't try it
and back to that example if you don't
try it you know failure is that she not
trying at the fear of failure actually
creates almost like a cancer if you fail
to try it then you know you've you've
let us all down because you could have
done I'd tell you Evan alter Leah today
if you have an idea you know if you back
yourself you're halfway there and and
what what is brilliant on what I love
doing more than anything is defying the
cynics loads of people could be cynical
or jealous people might be jealousy
you've had the idea and you're gonna
make your idea come to reality and
you're gonna make your dreams come true
um but I you know I'd back yourself and
I do you idea whatever happens you know
and it's amazing it you
never know what twists and turns lights
go in front of you so I'll give you
example when I left graduate school aha
and it was before the internet so I
wrote one of my buddies they give you an
example a real good buddy called paul
smith great guy he wrote 240 companies
240 companies and he only got a handful
of replies all of those turned him down
he didn't even get an interview but he
kept on going and just you know could
you much now demoralized that I got
turned down by so many comforters for
graduate school I even got turned down
this you know I applied to all these
great companies at the time called
Unilever and all these great PNG um and
they turn me down so what are they funny
thing this ever you know you in those
days you kind of did these placements I
did a four year course and I did kind of
two they call it a sandwich course a
placement of the company and the company
that I did a place from that BP I
thought I was a shoo-in for the job I
went to the job and I've got turned down
so I get over how does that work so um
but you just got to pick yourself up and
and what I would I would say there's a
few things in that sort of scenario one
of the things I asked for which is so
powerful that I don't think very few
people asked for is a magic word called
feedback and if people turn you down you
know whether it's for an audition if you
want to be an actor whether it's a
business person you did a pitch or if
you're gonna you know a later stage
company if you're going to raise money
and you do a pitch to your family you
know why are they back your why they
turn you down if you ask them feedback
it is mind-blowing how you can improve
your business your product your whole
sales pitch your website your social
experience so I think you know bottom
line link is you know back yourself defy
the cynics try your idea and constantly
have those social aunt and I on to say
you know how can I constantly improve
and course-correct my product and my
idea to make it land and make it big
I love it and Luke is loving that that
we picked his question so he's he's
happening the chat Luke I would say I
would say one back to our initial
comment at the top about the environment
the environment matters I would start
surrounding myself with with young
entrepreneurs who are off trying to do
something and if you don't have any
young entrepreneurs that you know go to
meet ups go to events try to try to
connect with them and if you still can't
find them then you know read articles
watch videos like learn from people who
are already doing it so that you know if
it's possible I think Mark Zuckerberg
big success made it possible for a lot
of young entrepreneurs realize hey if he
can do it I can do it too i mean i'm
going to bet on myself and then the
second thing i would think about is the
people who are giving you the advice and
maybe because they're jealous and maybe
because they love you like maybe mom and
dad love you and they just don't want to
see you fail they're not trying to hurt
you they think they're trying to help
you I would look at how the people who
are giving you this advice done it
before have they done it themselves and
if they haven't then they may not be in
the best position like the people were
hating on you if they haven't done it
themselves they haven't taken a change
themselves maybe they're not the best
people to kind of be given you that
advice i wouldn't pay attention to them
right and find out seek out the mentors
who you can learn from